hello welcome hello anslee let's start
by a bit of reflection on what happened
ten days ago particularly given you know
you lost the first one so as you look
back 110 days ago
unified world champion all the belts on
the table how do you feel
the main objective was victory that was
the main objective and also I still
train damn amateur club so to bring the
Bucks back to finish a boxing club I
still see the GB Olympic ways to take it
back up the GB boxing I feel that I have
achieved that goal because there was on
the other side of the world for a bit
and it was just important to bring them
back here to Britain so like I can just
keep on inspiring people and use these
as a tool to show it can be done and
even when you're facing adversity how
did what you did in the rematch change
what was different what do you do
differently
don't give away they'll come on it's
just about dedication what it what it is
is that when you're going through it
sometimes you're not learning it through
it but when I saw what it was like to be
heavyweight champion of the world
fruit and these eyes because I just come
in won the championship and they're just
like a roller coaster then I lost then I
was watching someone else from across
the road take the glory live the life of
a heavyweight champion that's what I
want some of that so it gave me a new
sense of focus and motivation how did
you celebrate
you weren't pictured falling out of a
nightclub I celebrate let my friends
event on Sunday like hang out we'd show
everyone comes together and yeah it's
just like amongst loads of local friends
and stuff I'm still the local voice I
was just amongst all the local friends
and that's it we're a bit bummed out so
I need to rest it's fine I need to rest
rather than party how different could
your life of being because we know your
history yeah you know you know you came
from from these part of London that you
sort of fell off the straight narrow a
little bit back in 2010 your life could
have been really different now why why
was it boxing that that grabbed you and
that that saved you from that okay yeah
it could have definitely been different
like it's weird because in my house is a
house of I respect you guys and I
haven't been raised with you I don't
know you from outside but I was always
taught to have respect
and that's so important I think for my
parents but when I used to leave their
house it was like what can I do now what
mischief can actually can I find and
what mischief can I get up to you but
boxing rather than going out I was out
and back in a safe environment in in a
place where everyone had the same goal
which was a positive one to be
successful in in a craft and was around
a lot of generations so people now older
than me people are older than them then
elder generation so that's a free
generation deep of knowledge that
they'll put into us which was good so in
terms of like correcting your wrongs I I
do think it should get trained in that
we want to see no no trouble no issues
in 2020 I think 2019 has been a lot of
issues on the streets and stuff of a lot
of kids and that's why I said bring
these bars back to show them through
adversity and hard times you can kind of
break the mold and I feel like you don't
have to have anything special I didn't
have anything with books and I just had
a pair trainers and shorts and we've
taken it to the world and I feel like
the next generation can do it better
than us
so when out there is quiet you know you
obviously really plugged into where you
grew up
yeah yeah is he there when you take the
belts back and you reflect on your own
story
do those avenues exist for kids there
today to try to make that change do you
think yeah I do think so I think even
better as well because there's more
information so I think like you can only
achieve what you see and so I'd their
itches or in my gym who's another
heavyweight and I wanted to kind of be
like him so he had won the a bas which
is becoming the best in London sorry in
England and then the next step for me we
went on have become the best in the
world
by going to the Olympics so imagine what
the next kid will do so that's why even
though they might not have the highest
facility-based gym in the local area if
they've got the drive that beats any
high-performance tech machines that are
out there that drive is is nature and
that's what we're trying to install in
these kids by showing them what I'm
about and showing them what they can
achieve it's it's really admirable what
you've what you've done what you've done
for community where you came from and
you can understand why it's important to
be successful it's important to make
money from the sport it's important to
show inspiration to the kids but did you
have any qualms about going out to Saudi
Arabia given the political situation out
there there's been a lot made of sport
washing and country's using sport to
improve their images how in your head
did you how did you weigh that up it was
interesting because when I when I took
the fight I said hear more about these
things so I've never been like heavily
into that politics or heavily into the
history of Saudi Arabia to a certain
degree but when I chose to fight that I
learned more about anything you have to
get in Saudi Arabia involved to make a
change and put a positive light so I
think that previously the country was
one way and honestly I think that the
crown prince is making efforts to make a
big change and then when I spoke to them
they said I know your boxing match was
important but the most important thing
for us was weighted down for Saudi
Arabia did you speak to the country yeah
yeah I'm am and this is a good saying is
that it was about bringing light to our
country to show me you're making efforts
to you know equality so I was women in
the stadium you know amongst their men
and you know stuff like that I couldn't
use the gym though in the hotel for
example yeah so interesting I think we
have to respect their culture as well I
understand that so that's their culture
and I think I respect that so that's
just the way of their life and I respect
that but in terms of the way they treat
people and stuff I think it was it was
positive it was a nice time and my mum
was there she never comes to any fights
she came out my son was there my niece
angel so it was a family orientated
place it wasn't as bad as I thought when
I heard about what the issues going on
previously actually because they're
making a positive change can can I ask
you said you don't particularly you're
personally interested in the politics of
that place and just generally but you
know looking back on some of the things
you said in the last year one of the
things you did say last year around the
time that Raheem Sterling was talking
about racism and football you sort of
came out and were quite supportive of
that stance and the fact that that needs
to change and I just wonder what what
you think about some of you know we saw
a couple weekends ago a band it was a
Manchester United Manchester City and
racist abuse and the football stands is
that something the experience in boxing
or not Navin lets you scared can I say
we've gits a lack of you have to you
have to get out your community in order
to see something I think it's just a
lack of education that's what I liked
about boxing is that different religions
different races different cultures all
in one room
same with football in one stadium to
enjoy a game of football so I don't know
why there the narrative changes towards
the skin color or its bizarre isn't it
because you know we saw something
yesterday and I think we've got a
picture of it in Italy this is their
anti racism campaign in Syria saying
let's not be racist and they've put up
three photos of so this is saying that
this relates back to the people you're
being racist to to a certain degree
they're trying to vary their explanation
of it is that they're flipping it back
on it so it's just that the people
trying to be creative in this error by I
think there's a lack of understanding of
the culture so before anyone kind of
makes a documentary so let's say it's
like an African Caribbean community
that's taking racism I think they should
get African Caribbeans involved in this
series so they can give it from a
perspective from their issue rather than
having someone who's not from that
background fix oh we're doing it we're
doing a good thing by making this
documentary but if you're not from that
background you don't know how you're
going to offend the people so is it
equality what inclusion is really
important if you're trying to spread a
message it's not just about how I want
to get the message across it's about
getting the people involved so you can
send the right message and it becomes a
more natural and realistic realistic
task are you surprised that racism still
is rearing its head in in sport not
necessarily because it's just the way of
the human make up I think some people
just have their way and some people have
other ways but I do feel like if you're
in one stadium for the same purpose
which is to enjoy a game of football I
just can't understand why the narrative
changes and I feel like we all add
something to the world and I have
background race religion and culture we
will add something
I think how can you take something so
negative about something so positive so
I think it's just it's not about
football it's not about the skin color
it's about that individual that needs
changing it's not on my skin colors
black so I'm worse or I'm better it's
that person over there no matter the
skin color or the race they've just got
certain issues that they need to
overcome and it's there if that's how
they choose to live their life they're
gonna take it to the grave of them and
you just hope that their kids improve
slightly going back to the politics what
do you think about the Rose yesterday
about Arsenal about China not showing
the Arsenal match Oh Joe I don't really
follow too much what you know but I
heard them midfielder yeah sort of
tweeted yeah yes it's about China and
it's not a relation to Arsenal to a
Saudi yeah
and trying to do it so it's a hard one
because I was trying to I don't think is
disrespecting China it's hard because
you want to make awareness of these
things and you're in a platform to be a
spokesman as well but that's why it's
certain athletes are just boring because
sometimes it's best to just do what you
do but maybe the same again he should
have spoken to someone from that country
involved someone in his conversation and
said how do you feel about this
situation that's going on in China they
never said look this is the situation
that's going on rather than it just
being from my point of view and that
goes back to their to the campaign that
they're making inclusion is more
important than just me spreading it from
my point of view yeah we don't have much
time but we want to ask you what you up
to for Christmas what's Christmas like
in the Joshua house all in a jar man if
my household isn't big enough I was such
a big family so you still live with your
mum yeah if I didn't I wouldn't see her
because I'm always out so it's important
for me to keep the family unit so it's
really important you as well isn't it
sorry the faith is really in place yeah
I prayed a lot ahead of this fight and
whether you're religious or not I think
it's important to put like positive
affirmations into the world yeah so
that's just a way of doing it some
people use religion some people use
affirmation so I prayed a lot but big
Christmas dinner of it I think I deserve
it